what's a happy number start with any  positive integer and find the sum of  squares of its digits and repeat the  process if we get a 1 in the process  which will of course loop back to 1 in  the end we can say that the number is a  happy one so 13 is a happy number what  about 7 7 squared is 49 4 squared plus 9  squared gives us 97 9 squared plus 7  squared gives us 130 1 squared plus 3  squared plus 0 squared gives us 10 1  squared plus 0 squared gives us one  seven is a happy number two here are  some of the initial happy numbers and  tell us something interesting you know  about happy numbers in the comment  section what are unhappy or sad numbers  by the way watch the next video  [Music]